hey everyone today i'm going to show you
how to photograph a couple with a height
difference hi guys my name is gerry
gionis i'm a wedding portrait and
fashion photographer
i've been photographing for 27 years and
teaching for 20.
i'm going to share some of that
experience with you right now and show
you
how to bring out the best in a couple
with the height difference and how to go
from this
to this and don't forget click on the
link below
or right up here to download my portrait
quick start
and enjoy for free so you have a couple
with a height difference
what do you do now traditionally a guy
will be taller than a girl
and we'll cover the other way around but
right now we're discussing the ideas on
how to actually make this look a little
bit more balanced here we have jacob
he's six foot
and we have rainey who's five foot five
she's wearing no shoes
makes it more difficult for me as well
uh i'll also even do a demonstration
with me and rainey because i'm six foot
two so we're gonna be bigger height
difference
now here's the thing we know there's a
height difference we just want to make
it more aesthetically pleasing
everyone knows that jacob for example is
taller than rainy
it's okay but if there's such a big
difference aesthetically it's going to
look a little bit weird
so how do you even up the scales and
make it look more aesthetically pleasing
we're going to take a shot like this a
before shot
and then show you how to get to
something that looks amazing
and to be honest we don't want to do it
in a way where jacob all of a sudden is
this hype that's going to look weird
we just want to make it so that you
don't look at a photograph of the couple
and straight away think well that looks
just weird it's a shame there's such a
big height difference
the photo doesn't look great so let's
get into it
what we're going to do um rainy all
right so let's just stand shoulder to
shoulder we can obviously see there's a
big height difference there
and looks like all right looking at the
camera
we're not worried about lighting at this
stage guys it's purely about height
difference
yes just so we can see we've basically
got an open garage door for the lights
that are coming in we have them on a
background
and right now i'm just going to shoot
them looking straight to the camera
great so how can we improve this well
let's do it
first of all we have to understand that
if you are photographing
full length it's going to be a bit less
forgiving
in other words he can squat down and
party's feet
and we can crop up close and you
wouldn't know that there is an issue
now that's always not going to be a
great thing so we need to do full length
how do we actually make this work with
full length let's do this
so what we're going to do first of all
we're going to turn jacob this way
okay and then we're going to turn the
rainy this way now
this is never going to work if they
stand on the same plane parallel to the
camera it's not gonna
it's not gonna work for us so here's
what we're gonna do we're gonna bring
rainy about a foot closer to the camera
a bit more
okay now if you've seen me teach before
and talk about posing tips for women
you'll know that in fact what i will
normally do is i'll get
the bride or the girl whoever i'm
photographing the model to point her toe
towards the camera
slide her heel back in and bend the knee
shift her butt back
shoulders back lean the chest forward
now what happens now though is
it's dropping her height quite
significantly maybe two three inches
but i do want her beautiful shape and
her curves
so all i do is i do those curves and i
do that kind of a pose but not so
pronounced
the way to do that get her to stand up
nice and straight and all i want you to
do is just
put one knee over the other perfect so
now we hardly drop some height but we do
get a bit of curve
and life is good so first of all let's
take that photograph
even though that she's standing closer
to me
okay so eyes at me both of you
okay in fact come one step closer there
for me ready
okay stop there great hold it
perfect so now here's the most important
thing
he keeps his left foot there
so again if we look at the difference
become nice and close here
if you look at the difference it's
probably well over a foot
so what's going to happen without
actually stepping on her toes
keep your left foot there and then bring
your right foot about
here good
okay so stay there for me i'm going to
take that photograph
to give you a progression
okay very good now the key is this
now what he does he keeps his left foot
there and he's going to lean his upper
body towards rainey
and now randy come closer to him this
way put your arms around each other
okay good and now let's just hold hands
in the front there to give you sort of
an idea
okay here's the actual most important
thing
okay so let's take a photograph of you
guys to show the height difference
all right so we don't want to call rainy
short
we called her down to earth she's very
closer to the earth
just a nice way of uh you know hashtag
you're short but it's all good
all right good hold it there for me hold
it good all right
so now what we need to do
is remind you if you haven't seen me
teach before and talk about posing the
female form
that if we get rainy to do the pose that
i quite like
in photographing women and that is to
turn the body on a bit of an angle
point the toe towards the camera slide
the heel back in bend the knee
shoulders back and then lean forward
towards the camera
she gets shorter and shorter so i
actually want
beautiful curves on her i actually want
to show her her figure and her form
the problem is again we're dropping
height further still so what we're going
to do is
do that pose but just less pronounced
the way i like to do it
stand up nice and straight without
thinking too much all i want you to do
is
bring one knee over the other perfect so
now we get the shape without dropping
the height
but what we have to do is this they
cannot stand on the same plane
rainey's going to stand about a foot
away okay so become nice and close over
here you'll see the difference
between their between their bodies so
it's literally
yeah so it's about that far away okay so
a bit more than a foot
all right so what we'll do let's come
back here now so even though that she's
closer to the camera it's no big deal
now what we'll do um so jacob i want you
to turn your body on a bit of an angle
let's get back in that little pose that
you did before so without stepping on
her
on her foot come a little bit more this
way and
keep your left foot there and bring your
right foot all the way this way
that's it and now rainy come a little
bit closer to me
good all right put your arms around each
other hold hands in the front
okay if you look at the perspective
and now rainy stay where you are jacob
lean forward with your upper body
towards me so that your faces are on the
same plane
and they'll close the gap together so
the forehead and the cheek there
right there and rainy looking at me okay
so now what we're going to do
okay so as you can see from my
perspective
one leg is covering up the other now it
looks really awkward
okay the fact is that if i can see a
part between his legs
it's going to be an issue so what i'm
going to do just so i can show the
awkwardness from a different angle
pretend like you're on a turntable and
you're twisting that way with the exact
same pose
keep going keep going keep going
good so your your left foot was a bit
further out there jacob that's good
okay and so just rest in again the
lighting is terrible we're not worried
about the lighting at this stage
but just to show you the gap there okay
hold it there
good good as in bad if that makes any
sense
but if you look at the difference we
went from standing shoulder to shoulder
big height difference we brought her
forward
we didn't want to get that pronounced
shape of her body too much
and then we put one leg one leg over the
other the key to this is from the
camera's perspective
his front leg his right leg the one
that's actually now he's putting all his
weight on his front leg
is about one foot or more beyond the
other leg
and she's bending her knee without
dropping her height
and life is good and of course if he so
actually just say that for a second
that's a that's a good progression
to do now that you're there good
so if you keep straight another thing we
can do is this
if rainey stays straight but then jacob
leans forward
so if you can lean forward mate and then
you tilt
and then rainy stays straight and you
just come a little bit closer to me
rainy
that's it good see now we're looking at
a more aesthetically pleasing photograph
without dramatically going quickly let's
go back shoulder to shoulder to show the
difference very quickly
without seeing this ridiculous height
difference
now because i'm a little bit taller than
jacob let's do this
now you might be asking why am i wearing
shorts
it's las vegas and it's close to 40
degrees which is um
100 degrees here in vegas so and it's my
house i can do what i want
all right so jacob you relax over there
mate
so let's say um okay we'll do it we'll
do it this way
all right so right now so ronnie if you
come over there for me a couple steps
forward
turn on a bit of an angle okay and again
just one knee over the other not too
pronounced
so again i'm actually standing about
this far away from her
now what i do is i leave my right foot
there
i i lean with my left foot she puts her
arm around this way
she keeps her face straight and i tilt
to add a little bit of intimacy we hold
hands
and that's how we do it now i'm not too
sure what the camera can see but
hopefully
you do not see a gap between my legs if
you can
i just shuffle around and of course if
i'm wearing pants it would be
that sounds a bit weird if i'm wearing
pants um
the pants will overlap the other pant
leg
a lot easier so that's pretty much how
you're going to do it
now here's what's going to happen guys
we'll do the same kind of pose
with what i think you guys call in
america the graduation pose the hugging
from behind shot
we'll do the same shot hugging from
behind and see if it's the same thing
let's do it all right jacob let's get
back mate so i want you to hug her from
behind
but stand up nice and straight
yep so skips nice and straight like that
perfect
perfect as in bad if that makes any
sense all right hold it there
hold it good so as you can see
the height difference is there he's
almost a full head above her and it's
going to look a little bit weird in the
photograph
so what we're going to do is this the
exact same thing so rainy if you come a
little bit closer to me
keep on coming keep on coming keep on
coming don't be shy
a bit more good point just point your
toe towards me just a little bit
slide it back and just a little bit of a
knee there great now jacob keep your
left foot there
and i want you to actually lean forward
with your right leg
perfect and now rainy turn your face
this way
and then jacob upper body more towards
me and then turn your face this way
that's good now as you can see from
from my angle his leg is covering up his
other leg and
in other words we do not see a gap as we
mentioned before
this is going to look great so now all
we do is
we take the shot perfect life is good
now again
what we'll do if you can pretend you're
on a turntable you keep the exact pose
and now i'm going to turn you that way
so we can see the awkwardness of what
you're doing
okay so as you can see uh and guys a
couple steps forward that way
yep perfect so again ignore the lighting
we're not worried about the lighting the
lighting is horrible in this photograph
i could turn them around we've already
got it here
it looks ridiculous from a different
angle so remember
posing in any form let alone actually
posing for height differences
usually it's going to be one angle one
perspective is going to be better
so that's going to be a good thing for
you guys okay
relax guys check that out a little bit
all right
so now of course if we are photographing
closer up
we can hide that difference very easily
and i know this is very basic
but rather than getting someone to do
this this is sort of like squatting
and it is squatting but basically it's
going to be tough to hold on the legs
it's going to be a lot easier to do this
for a guy to shorten him his height
rather than to do this so quite simply
um let's do that so turn this around
what i want you to do or in fact what i
want you never to do
is to say to a guy or a girl spread your
legs
it's the worst thing i said it on my
first professional shoot i sounded
terrible
it was a little bit creepy and you can't
say that so for a guy or a girl you say
part your feet part your knees it's the
best way of doing it so
pat your feet even more so
good and i want you to go for a bit of a
cuddle
yep and i want your temple just on his
cheek there
so come a little bit closer there ronnie
yeah and then you're going to tilt more
perfect and then just bring this hand on
here
just like that nice and sort of soft
good
and then rainy set up a little bit
straighter there for me good and then
this hand can just go over here
and again you're tilting this way good
so now he's parting his
feet in fact you know what
it's funny because we got to the same
sort of position anyway that we did
before
um so usually what happens when when i
say
to someone part your feet it'll normally
be straight
like that and the straightness of it is
not going to work
you normally want that bent a little bit
otherwise it looks a bit a little bit a
little bit stiff
and there's no energy shifting to the
next person but he managed to actually
bend that knee in without me asking so
it might be a good starting off point a
common denominator for you guys
to look at so again very quickly i can
take
this shot or i can go closer
and even if his legs look a little bit
uncomfortable
i do not see that problem now for the
sake of the argument because now the
lighting is nice but i want to make it a
little bit nicer
rainy if you could bring your face a bit
more this way stop there tilt this way
more mate
and then turn this way stop and i want
you looking this way
okay so now of course if there was any
awkwardness actually in their legs
even though that we're disguising it by
put one of his legs over the other
and there's no gap between them simply
by by going close up and parting his
feet or parting his knees
it ends up being really really good and
of course she stays straight and he can
tilt his face with drops a few couple of
inches as well
and then we take a shot nice and easy
now here's another thing we can do watch
this
if i simply go close to them and i have
a non-descript background like i do
so this is just a canvas background if i
tilt the camera
one way or the other it's actually going
to make
it's going to give us an illusion that
one person is taller than the other
so this could be the same thing when
you're shooting vertically or
horizontally so
when i say vertically portrait often
people refer to as portrait or landscape
as in horizontal so what i'm going to do
now if you just drop your hand there for
me rainey
that would be awesome okay i'm just
going to focus on them like this
okay so now i'm photographing them close
up
great so now i'm going to tilt the
camera one way and tilt it the other
and there'll be an illusion that one
person is actually even taller than the
other
and the other way we balance up the
scales a little bit so even though that
we've done what we've done with the feet
in this case with part of the feet to
remind you i've taken a shot just close
up
and basically nice and vertical and
straight
but now what i'm going to do is i am
going to
tilt towards raining
okay quite severely the thing is you
don't know you have no reference point
of any strong horizontal or vertical
lines
the fact that i'm actually tilting the
camera so first
i'm just going to do that so eyes at me
good
now let me go the other way
let me have a look here i will have to
do it the
i'll have to do it handheld which is
totally fine
good eyes of me perfect
all right so now you're going to notice
a couple of
incredible things in camera before i
drop my camera and it falls and it'll be
a youtube hit
so as you can see when i tilt
to the left i'm actually going to make
him look ridiculously taller
if i tilt to the right as in in the
favor of the person that i actually want
to make
taller then i'm going to make her look
taller we even up the scales a little
bit
so tilting can be a great thing if
you're in an environment where you do
have strong horizontal lines or vertical
lines and you tilt the camera
you can tell it's being tilted it's
really up to you and your comfort level
as to if you're happy to have
that happen as in which is the lesser of
the evils your frame not being
symmetrical with vertical and horizontal
lines
or the height differences being better
or worse totally up to you
all right let's try something else what
happens if they're walking how do we
correct that let's do it right now
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
lower my camera angle and
it'll all be revealed as to why i'm
doing that in a moment so let me lower
my camera angle
so what happens when your couple are
walking
let's say you want to do walking shots
and you
want to just even up the odds with the
height difference well how would you do
that well
simple it's all about perspective so
let's say if they're walking and they're
holding hands
so let's do that i want you one step
forward
um and stay where you are mate so give
me a walking motion without actually
walking
so in fact bring that foot right behind
you that's it perfect
rainy come a little bit closer this way
and come a bit more back more jacob
good and if you put one foot more over
the other
oh too much come back and then that heel
just back
yep perfect good hand in the pocket
reigning a little bit closer good and
then put one foot over the other
okay so here's what happens they're
walking
and quite simply she is closer to the
camera and he is further away
so if you do want walking shots i want
you to shoot a little bit lower and
biased to her side and that will even up
the odds a little bit
all right let's do that if you guys knew
the exact same thing that you're doing
but a few steps this way
stop there good and then jacob bring
your left foot back a bit mate
a bit more good okay
you know we're not after a perfect shot
here we're just giving you some examples
as to how this can work
good rainy a touch closer to me good
in fact i might even come a little bit
more biased to your side perfect
that looks awesome now just for the sake
of the argument there i
want you to pretend like you're just
holding your dress there as you sort of
walk in
good both of you look at the actual
about the light there
perfect hold it there hold it there hold
it
good so as you can see clearly from my
direction and from this particular angle
i'm shooting bias to the person i want
to make taller
and she's a little bit closer to
actually to me than him
and life is good let's show you the
difference between what that would look
like if they were holding hands
and then walking normally at on the same
plane and
parallel to the camera so like just give
me one step forward both of you if you
can
that's good hold it there
see huge difference between just getting
them to walk naturally
and a huge difference between actually
shooting with rainy a little bit more
forward and biased to her side
now let's say for example you wanted to
even up the odds a little bit let's say
you were photographing a couple or a
bride and a groom walking down the aisle
how do you fix that because you don't
have no chance of directing them hey
bride stand a bit closer they just got
married it wouldn't be appropriate
there's a short little aisle that is
when of course again
you will tilt the camera and again if
you're happy
that the the vertical lines and the
horizontal lines in your environment
aren't parallel to the frame it's either
you just accept it that's the height
difference big deal what can we do
or take that clean shot and then
tilt the camera so then the the
the bride and the groom or the couple
that you're photographing are a similar
height difference so let me explain
again if you're looking at my hands
there's my hand okay there's a taller
person that's the shorter person
if we actually angle this way this
taller person looks even taller
if we angle this way do you see how that
difference is lessened
therefore more aesthetically pleasing
that's a really important one
a couple of other quick suggestions when
you're photographing a couple
and you've got a height difference if
you get the couple to sit on a chair
so jacob if you take a seat on there you
can
lower it here with a lever so take a
seat make yourself comfortable
okay perfect just like that good
and rainy i want you to just stand but
just right in there and put your arms
around him
put your arm around the waist and then
over the shoulder there i mean him
around the waist and you can sort of
hold hands in front we're not too
worried about the exact sort of posing
here
we're just sort of giving you an idea so
turn your bodies this way good
close the gap with your faces perfect
so as you can see very quickly and very
simply
he can sit down she can stand up and
then we've got a great shot
how else can we do it well let's
get you can you pull the lever of the
chair so you're down to a point where
your feet are flat on the ground
okay so of course we can also get her to
sit on his lap
let's do that so you're going to sit
right over here
i want you to put this knee over the
other one good
arm around there as well cuddle in nice
and tight you can hold hands in front
again we're not worried we're not this
is not a lesson on perfect posing at the
moment it's more about posing
couples with a height difference of
course and again
we get a nice shot perfect okay great
now he can stay there she can stand up
again
she can cuddle him from behind let's do
that so just over here
sort of reminds me of the uh the step
brothers uh
the step brothers movie
[Laughter]
all right so what i want you to do is
just want you just your hand over here
lean forward bring this hand right over
yeah this one can just sort of stay out
of the way good turn your faces this way
good rainy come a bit closer and then
bend that knee a little bit this way
towards me can i be closer towards me
just
be on that chair that's good good
perfect
nice there we go and again we're sort of
disguising the height difference put
your hand in your pocket then mate your
left hand
we're disguising the height difference
and guys looking at me if you can
just like that hold it there perfect
very good
all right so now what else can we use in
our environment what's a common thing
that we can use
on the street or in in in different
environments whether it's in a house or
a hotel
of course it's either the curb it could
be a simple
uh street curb a gutter is that what you
guys call it a gutter
or a gutter we're gonna shoot in a
gutter
but you don't want to say to the guy can
you get in the gutter and then get her
on top but this is in fact
what we're going to emulate with the
apple box so let's do that
so this is just an ordinary apple box um
i wasn't going to make my life a bit too
easy by giving
me a bigger one but let's just say that
was the that was the size or the depth
and the height of the
of the gutter so here's what we can do
so let's get you off the chair
and again you just go to the street go
to the street
okay get him in the gutter so you're
here on the ground
like that and again you're coming way
back here perfect and now
rainey stand on here for me and face
this way so if you want to
do the good old point the toe towards
the camera slide the heel back in she
just knows it
okay now keep your foot there okay so
keep your left foot there we're still
doing the
leaning forward about a foot apart but
not probably that pronounced so come a
little bit closer with your feet
good close the gap hold your hands
together and you see how an ordinary
street curb
can actually make a bit of a difference
now you can even
show the fact that he's standing in the
gutter
that's okay or you can simply disguise
it
love it both of them are giving me blue
steel in many ways it's awesome
let's have a look
perfect all right so again i'm not
worried about the nuances of all the
bits and pieces this is just a way to
get the height differences a lot better
so that's going to work well for us
also imagine we're on a staircase
okay so let's say there's simple stairs
coming up
fantastic very easy so you would say a
staircase would be about that
that rise so again
yep if you can stand up so she's
standing on the staircase
um in this case we'll do something a
little bit different so maybe we'll um
come around this way like you know what
ronnie turn this way
and then let's say you're down this way
so she's up the stairs he's
down one stair or two for that matter
and again i want you to cuddle her from
behind
yep so color from your handing on the
hips hands on the hands
turn your face into his
lean forward and turn your face this way
perfect
awesome all right guys again looking
this way
switch your body weight and your legs
there randy
beautiful hold there guys hold it
perfect so again use stuff that's it in
your environment it could be
anything it doesn't really matter here's
the thing
there is a height difference between
couples that's just going to be a fact
people know that there's a ridiculous
difference between the guy and the girl
and sometimes it could be the opposite
you know the girl could be actually
really really tall the guy can be
shorter
the same thing happens we do the exact
same thing she puts one foot back
she puts her front foot forward and then
bends her knee but rather than putting
all her weight on her back leg
she would put weight on her front leg
does that make sense
so rather than so let's say for example
we're like this
and she's just putting her leg that way
putting all her weight on her back leg
if she was a taller girl and a shorter
guy she would simply
shift the weight on her front leg bend
that knee
and then you would get the guy standing
nice and straight
now don't forget guys too we have to
understand that we're actually giving
you an example of a heterosexual couple
this could be the same concept with two
guys or two girls
these same principles apply in
everything that we've said
also just simply be creative it could
also simply
be that maybe i think we did this before
but
you know he could be sitting down
and we got her to cuddle from behind
before so turn that way
and she could just be standing nice and
straight so turn this way
um can you bring the chair a little bit
this way perfect
and i want you to bring your elbow just
here this is more of an editorial so
oh that's cute too but you know i do
this way so hand on the hip
and then this one just on here yeah
beautiful
good and then come a bit closer and then
shift your body weight the other way
so which so yeah that way there you go
come closer to me
and then just you know this is like a
power couple you know just like that
perfect
and then you're turning face this way
good come a little bit closer
again so she can stand nice and tall
and then he's sort of sitting there like
that
and now we're looking at me guys good
actually ready come back a little bit
that's it bring your hand a bit more out
so i can see more of that more of the
arm like this
good and now turn your body more jacob
this way
good okay perfect and again this could
look awesome full length
perfect great guys hold it fantastic
so guys not rocket science it's a bit of
practice don't be afraid of it
and you might say jerry what happens if
there's actually a bigger height
difference
guys no joke i once photographed a five
foot two girl
marrying a seven foot two guy he was the
second tallest man in western australia
it was ridiculous like it was an amazing
difference i just battled through it
simply the best that i could so if i
were you before you go out and do a real
shoot with it with a couple
let's say if you're doing a paid gig go
get that tall cousin of yours and go get
that
down to earth short niece of yours get
them together and practice so that when
you are shooting
for reals it's going to be a lot easier
hope you enjoyed that guys
and like i said repetition experience
and practice will always be your best
teacher
hey everyone thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed that video
also do me a favor give me a thumbs up
please subscribe and don't forget to
click on that bell for notifications of
future episodes
also leave me a comment i'd love to hear
from you answer any of your questions
and stay connected and remember you
don't have to be the best
you just got to be better than last week
you